let's go next to our caller from the
4-1-0
area code who's calling today from 4-1-0
hey david my name's jim did you say tim
or
jim jim with a j jim with a j
alright what's going on jim uh thanks
for taking the call man i
hope everything's staying healthy and
you're well thank you
oh i just i i i'm just going to to get
your read on
the q a on stuff and
i i'm curious to see what percentage you
think of the
right is sort of
uh is on board with some of that that
stuff and it's
you know i've only just kind of started
to hear about the q and on stuff and
um it seems problematic i'm just i'm
curious what your read is on how
how much you might see that on the right
side of the aisle so
i don't have any independent assessment
but earlier this week i interviewed alex
kaplan from media matters and alex said
that
we're probably talking about millions
but not tens of millions that's that's
the
the current assessment that alex had and
i would i would you know
defer to him on that um and that seems
about right if you look at sort of like
tweet
volume and facebook groups and remember
some of these movements
seem larger when you're looking at the
internet
but they're really not that big and you
know we saw that
we've seen that with a lot of different
movements i think this is what surprised
a lot of people during the democratic
primary how did joe biden get all these
millions of votes
well if you just look online the sort of
bernie aoc
left seems bigger than it actually is
and that's not a praise or criticism
it's just a reality
i think that that may make q anon seem
like a bigger thing than it is but it
certainly seems to be in the millions
but short of tens of millions
yeah yeah yeah uh and so you don't think
that necessarily it might
have um it might it might not have a
massive
impact on sort of you won't see that
sort of votership
reflected as much as one might think
based on headlines and stuff
in the actual vote in in the popular
vote in total
no but remember that there's 20
candidates
that are q anon affiliated on the ballot
in november
two of whom seem to have a real shot at
winning again according to what alex
kaplan told us earlier this week
i think if you get two cue and honors in
the house of representatives that's
going to start to take on
a little bit of a different picture
right
yeah and so you would think then that
most of the conservative bases
is more moderate or do you think it's
all right something that
that's maybe a larger part of the
constituency or no here's the thing
when you have something like q anon it
doesn't really help us to assess
where the republican party is in general
because the these are really at least
for now
this is a relatively small group these
are outliers these are sort of it's it's
like a
it's a slice of trumpists and trumpists
are a slice of the republican party so i
don't really think that
q a non-existing tells us much about
the broader dynamics of the republican
party but you're getting to something
that i think is really important which
is
whenever trump leaves whether it's in
january or january of 2025 whenever that
is
what happens to the trumpists that are
left over
and how does that manifest in the senate
and the house of representatives
in governor's mansions state senate etc
and that's more of an open question but
i wouldn't make any assessments about
the republican party from q anon really
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense and
i think um
you know just building on that you would
say
the majority of republicans maybe are
are
uh more moderate or more reasonable than
sort of those fringe groups so that
maybe well listen
if the if the standard for the
republican party has become
very radical over the last 20 years if
we're comparing to q anon
then okay i don't i don't think the
majority of the republican party does
not have
the beliefs of q anon but they have
their own radical beliefs in their own
way
sometimes they're radical religious
beliefs sometimes they're radical
authoritarian beliefs sometimes they're
just
really widely debunked economic ideas so
it's not like a bailout for republicans
that they're not all as crazy as qanon
if you know what i mean
right yeah totally yeah yeah that's
great
and i think uh the comparison to the aoc
bernie
stuff seems relevant to me but but do
you do you feel that there's a similar
sort of
striation of the party on our side of
the aisle as well or
i think the dynamics are very very
different because
some of these extreme movements some of
these extreme movements exist on the
left where they're so extreme that
they're not even really on the spectrum
of sort of like the normal political
spectrum where q anon is wacky it's like
this
these pizza gators and that type of
thing for the most part like the bernie
aoc wing of the democratic party
they're mostly voting for joe biden they
understand biden's closer to them than
trump and it makes sense to remove trump
that's like a normal way to interact
with the political system here in
massachusetts we had these primaries
everybody i know who supported joe
kennedy or alex morse
is now tweeting and posting that like
okay our person lost
but we're obviously voting for marky and
richard neal because they're better than
the alternatives
most people are operating in that way a
lot of the q anon people
are in a totally different universe
where they're not even on the political
spectrum in a normal way
right so so so how then
how would you compare can you
give me more sort of i guess clarity on
how you would compare
the asc bernie sanders type of spectrum
you're talking about two of the queue
and i'm like do you think
aoc and bernie are are
closer to to the center than like the q
arms or do you think
uh i think it's the i just think it's
the wrong analysis
i don't know that you can you know
conspiracy theorists it's very tough to
put them on the political spectrum i
mean look at anti-vaxx as an example
you have people that end up as anti-vaxx
on the right because they're skeptical
of government
and you have people that end up
anti-vaxx on the left because they're
skeptical
of businesses and they share their
anti-vac sentiment but if you say where
are they on the political spectrum
they're both they're all over it and
some are not on it at all like they're
not political
other than they are anti-vaxx so i just
don't think we can really
analyze it in such a sensible rational
way yeah
gotcha yeah yeah yeah that makes a lot
of sense
um cool i i can't think anything else to
ask you but
um all right i appreciate the phone call
yeah of course thank you thank you for
calling
david thank you great to hear from you
we are going to go
to a break and we will take calls again
very very soon real quick i want to tell
you about our sponsor
magic spoon who have done something
awesome they've taken
all of our favorite sugary childhood
cereals that we know we shouldn't eat
anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult there's four flavors
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry they
taste great they're crunchy
they're sweet like you would expect this
type of cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n